ده الامور خرجت عن السيطره هناك فوضى
عالمه الان في شوارع العاصمه باريسنا
بالقرب على بعض امتار من ساحه الجمهوريه
تعزيزات امنيه من كل صوب الان تاتي هنا
على يميني كما ترون الشرطه تحاول تفريق
المتظاهرين المتظاهرون يردون عليها ب
رشقها بالحجاره والمقذوفات
ايضا يقومون بعمليات احراق كما ترون هنا
قاموا بقلب سيارات وباحرقها
الشرطه الان
المتظاهرين من كل الاتجاهات
طبعا ما حدث ان التظاهره كانت تسير بشكل
سلمي الى حد بعيد لم يكن هناك اي توتر لكن
فجاه مررت سياره من جانب المتظاهرين وعلى
ما يبدو انه السائق اطلقه تفادي ضد
المتظاهرين ليس لدي تاكيدات لكن راينا
المتظاهرين يتراكضون فجاه خلف هذه السياره
ويحاولون الامساك بها وهنا بدات تندلع
المواجهات عمليات التحطيم والتكسير للمحل
التجاريه للوحات الاعلانيه في الشوارع
لايضا
قاموا بتحطيم عدد كبير من مواقف الباصات
التي تتواجد هنا في الشارع فوضى عارمه
يقومون باشعال الحرائق في منتصف الطريق
الشرطه الان تقريبا
يعني كمان اشاهد الان هناك مواجهات بين
المتعه
لكن تعزيزات تمنيه هل هي من قبل قوات
الشرطه امم من قبل القوى
بعض الوكاله
لم ارى قواتي مكافحه الارهاب في مثل هذه
النوع من التظاهرات من ينتشر من رجال
الشرطههم همم القوات مكافحه الشغب والشرطه
الفرنسيه
ترعون حتى هناك عدد من الاشخاص الذين
يحاولون اطفاء هذا الحريق الذي ينزل هذا
احد السكان ربما في هذه المنطقه يحاول
اطفاء السياره التي اشعلها
المتظاهرين الشرطه تتقدم هناك ربما باتجاه
المتظاهرين الذين يرشقونها بالحجاره